Game of Thrones prequel series, House of the
Dragon, though based on the George RR Martin's
Targaryen history book Fire & Blood, will
not feature Targaryens only but many other
houses and many other legendary figures from
that time period as well.
From Lord Larys Strong who is pretty much
a combination of Varys and Littlefinger to
Alys Rivers who has the same abilities as
Melisandre and likely is Melisandre in her
younger days, to Nettles, a dragonseed, who
was either Daemon's secret child or his lover,
or even both.
We also have Cregan Stark, Roddy the Ruin
and his legendary Winter Wolfs.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
Fire And Blood is about long and rich history
of House Targaryen.
The key event of the show is also the key
in a history of House Targaryen, the Dance
of the Dragons - the Targaryen civil war,
which divided the entire kingdom and launched
a huge war that was fought from 129 AC to
131 AC.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne. When people started declaring
for one of them or the other, their fight
divided the kingdoms in two.
Targaryens fought Targaryens, bothers fought
brothers, dragons fought dragons. By the time
it was over, thousands were dead.
Not Targaryens, but Northmen, Cregan Stark,
Roddy the Ruin and his Winter Wolves play
a big role in the Dance of the Dragons with
Cregan even becoming the main character at
one point,
but for the most part he's legendary side
character.
Cregan Stark, known as the Old Man of the
North, The Wolf of the North and The Wolf
of Winterfell, was the Lord of Winterfell
and head of House Stark during the Targaryn
civil war.
Before fighting someone else's war, Cregan
had to fight his own war to get what was rightfully
his, to take the rule of the North from his
uncle upon himself.
Three years before the Dance of the Dragons
started, in 126 AC, Cregan finally rose up
against his uncle, and imprisoned Bennard
and his three sons, taking the rule of the
north into his own hands.
Upon the death of King Viserys I Targaryen,
Rhaenyra's son Prince Jacaerys Velaryon flew
to Winterfell on his dragon Vermax to gain
the support of the Starks and the north for
his mother Rhaenyra Targaryen's claim to the
Iron Throne.
The alliance, known as the Pact of Ice and
Fire, stated that a Targaryen princess, the
future firstborn daughter of Jacaerys, would
marry his son Rickon. Cregan pledged his support
to the blacks during the Dance of the Dragons.
After Prince Jacaerys Velaryon secured the
allegiance of the North for his mother Rhaenyra
Targaryen, Lord Cregan Stark sent two thousand
soldiers known as the Winter Wolves south
commanded by his bannerman Lord Roderick Dustin
known as Roddy the Ruin to support the Queen's
claim while he remained in the North to gather
his own banners (due to the vastness of the
North this would take long).
By the start of the Dance of the Dragons,
Roderick was an old and hoary warrior.
Despite his advanced age, he was still considered
a savage combatant on the battlefield.
Roddy the Ruin wore a shield, a helm, and
warhorn in battle.
The Winter Wolves were grizzled soldiers who
rode shaggy northern horses, wore old mail
and ragged skins and wielded axes, mauls,
spiked maces and ancient iron swords.
''We have come to die for the dragon queen.''
said Lord Roderick while leading 2000 Winter
Wolfs into battle.
There is probably nothing scarier than fighting
men who have come to die.
During the Battle by the Lakeshore, the Winter
Wolves led the attack and charged the Lannister
spearmen five times, with two thirds of the
Northmen killed or wounded in their decisive
victory for the blacks.
During the Butcher's Ball, Lord Roderick sounded
the charge of the Winter Wolves and their
river knight allies against Ser Criston Criston's
army in the ensuing Butcher's Ball, a slaughter
of the greens.
During the First Battle of Tumbleton, the
surviving Winter Wolves screamed northern
war cries and rode from a postern gate. Despite
being outnumbered by ten to one, Roddy the
Ruin led the northmen in a charge against
Lord Ormund Hightower.
As the singers tell it, Roddy was blood from
head to heel as he came on, yet so drunk with
battle that he did not even seem to feel his
wounds.
Lord Ormund's nephew, Ser Bryndon, was able
to cut off Roderick's shield arm with a longaxe,
but the nortern lord was able to kill both
Hightowers before succumbing to his wounds.
Rhaenyra fled King's Landing after the Storming
of the Dragonpit. While she was staying at
Duskendale, Lord Stark wrote that he would
gather for her a host of ten thousand northmen
younger and fiercer than the fallen Winter
Wolves.
Rhaenyra was killed at Dragonstone by King
Aegon II Targaryen, however, but Cregan with
his army still marched south nontheless in
support of her son, Prince Aegon the Younger.
He moved his forces to claim King's Landing
where he found that Aegon II had been poisoned
and Aegon III was now king.
This event came to be known as the 'Hour of
the Wolf' or the 'Judgment of the Wolf' in
which Cregan ruled Kings Landing and brought
justice upon all the betrayers and turn cloaks.
Speaking about betrayers, Larys Strong will
also be an epic side character in the upcoming
prequel series. Larys Strong is a combination
of Varys and Littlefinger, being the one in
shadows, orchestrating many events and deaths
of powerful people, making kings rise and
fall.
Larys Strong, known as Larys Clubfoot or the
Clubfoot, was the Lord of Harrenhal and head
of House Strong. He served on the small council
as the master of whisperers and Lord Confessor
for both kings.
Larys rarely spoke, preferring to listen.
His older brother, Harwin the Strong is rumored
to have fathered three of Rhaenyra's children.
Historians are still baffled as to exactly
what Clubfoot's loyalties and goals were during
the Dance of the Dragons as he sided with
Aegon, but at the end orchestrated his death.
Aside from possibly having his father and
brother killed to become lord of House Strong,
everything he does during the Targaryen civil
war is a mix of duty to the realm and self-preservation.
Like Varys, he stays loyal to his designated
monarch until that monarch threatens to bring
the realm down with him. Like Littlefinger,
he orchestrates that monarch's death once
he becomes too much of a problem, switches
sides and decides to create his own rule by
reigning through an underage ruler.
Fortunes turned against Lord Strong and his
plotters with the arrival of the northern
army of Lord Cregan Stark, who served as Hand
of the King to the new King Aegon III Targaryen
during the Hour of the Wolf. Despite having
been a supporter of Rhaenyra, Cregan objected
to the murder of Aegon II.
Grand Maester Orwyle confessed to having given
Larys the poison used to kill Aegon,
and Ser Perkin confessed to being the Clubfoot's
agent. While Lord Corlys admitted to having
conspired against Aegon for the good of the
Seven Kingdoms, Larys refused to confirm or
deny Cregan's accusations. Lord Stark condemned
both of the great lords, but Alysanne Blackwood
convinced him to spare Lord Velaryon. While
most of those found guilty took the black
and joined the Night's Watch,
Lord Larys chose death over the Wall. Cregan
beheaded him with his Valyrian steel greatsword,
Ice.
Next we have Nettles who is believed to be
either Daemon's secret child or lover.
Nettles, also known as Netty, was a dragonseed
and the first and possibly last dragonrider
of the dragon Sheepstealer. Nettles was able
to tame the wild dragon Sheepstealer by bringing
it a freshly slaughtered sheep each morning.
According to Mushroom, Daemon had come to
love the girl and took her as his bedmate.
In contrast, the maester at Maidenpool where
the two stayed, stated the dragonriders had
separate bedrooms and that Daemon doted upon
Nettles "as a man might dote upon his daughter".
When Maester Norren informed Daemon that Rhaenyra
had declared Nettles a traitor, believing
all dragonseeds are traitors and believing
Nettles poisoned Daemon's mind, Daemon disobeyed
his queen and his wife's order and allowed
Nettles to escape.
In her exile she went to the Vale of Arryn.
Last but not least we have Alys Rivers who's
origins are shrouded in mystery with some
believing she is Melisandre herself in her
younger days.
Alys looked unusually young for her age, as
she had to be at least forty by the outbreak
of the Dance of the Dragons and some even
believe she was much older than that.
Alys Rivers was a bedmate of Prince Aemond
Targaryen. Like Melisandre, she saw visions
in fire,
thats how Aemond learned that Daemon was waiting
for him in Harrenhal.
When Prince Aemond flew back to Harrenhal
to do battle with Prince Daemon and Caraxes,
he took the pregnant Alys with him. Aemond
told Daemon that it was Alys who told him
where to find him, as she saw a vision in
a fire.
After Daemon killed Aemond, Alys became the
witch queen, ruling Harrenhal.
The Hand of the King at the time, Ser Tyland
Lannister, tasked Ser Regis Groves of the
Kingsguard and Ser Damon Darry with reclaiming
the castle and gave them one hundred men.
Instead of yielding, Alys presented them a
young boy as Aemond's trueborn son and the
rightful king instead of Aegon III Targaryen.
Regis abruptly died after insulting Alys.
Eye witnesses claim she used magic to burst
his skull. Alys's rabble then rode from Harrenhal
and overwhelmed the loyalist men,
with Damon fleeing with the remaining men.
Alys sent a captured loyalist as a messenger
the following day. The survivor claimed that
he had been cursed by Alys so that he would
die if anyone laughed at his story. He said
Alys had instructed him that any man who approached
Harrenhal without submitting to its occupants
would die. The man also insisted that he had
seen a dragon inside. Despite Damon's assurance
that no one would laugh at the messenger's
story, one onlooker did so. The messenger
then choked to death in moments, with some
saying they had seen the imprints of a woman's
fingers on his throat. Her story will continue
when George RR Martin finishes Fire And Blood
volume 2.
Legendary side characters such as Cregan Stark,
Roddy the Ruin, Nettles, Larys and Alys, legendary
battles such as the Winter Wolfs' charge into
the Greens army despite being outnumbered
by ten to one and managing to reach the commander
of the greens, and seeing a Stark rule the
capital Kings Landing, all of that and more
this Game of Thrones prequel show, House of
the Dragon, brings in 2022.
Thank you so much for watching, hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did make sure to give
it a big thumbs up and I hope to see you in
the next one, peace!